the Ark of the Covenant is likely hidden
away at the Vatican or at the church of
our Lady Mary of Zion there have been
two major going theories in the Jewish
Community as to where the Ark of the
Covenant is one of them is that it's
buried in the Temple Mount somewhere the
the Jews saw the Romans coming and
they're like we are squirreling this
away and the easiest place to put this
is like somewhere underneath here which
has been going theory for a very long
time uh and then the secondary theory is
that you guys have it that's it again
really yeah because because there have
been long-standing rumors that the
Vatican inherited much of the wealth of
the Roman Empire and so after the fall
of Judea a lot of that stuff ended up
being kept by the Catholic Church wow
because it's like you look you go into
the museums and you're like oh there's
that uh you know Raphael painting but
like I don't know man you got the Ark of
the Covenant you're probably putting
that in like the like the special Locker
if somebody were to have it the
Catholics aren't a horrible bet
considering that when you go through
Rome one of my favorite things is where
it's just a giant Egyptian obelisk and
then boom stick across on it it's like
this is ours now